this isn't gonna work we play a lot of
nerf around this office we have almost
every type of nerf gun you can think of
however I've never seen a nerf sniper
rifle that actually acts as a sniper
rifle I want to build from scratch the
most powerful and accurate nerf sniper
rifle I just want to see what it takes
so one of my goals going into this build
is not just to make a gun that can shoot
a Nerf dart really fast no I want to
shoot a Nerf dart with style so instead
of modding an existing nerf gun out
there I decided to build my nerf gun
from scratch and how I'm gonna do that
is pneumatic air pressure I scoured a
lot of different tutorials cuz I'd never
built a pneumatic cannon before I found
this channel called top city gear he
builds this pneumatic air cannon he had
one awesome no too awesome design
elements that he incorporated and this
was the idea of taking an old drill like
just a power drill and using that as a
trigger mechanism to release the air now
accomplish that by hooking up the power
from the trigger into a sprinkler valve
so when you pull the trigger
theoretically the sprinkler valve
releases the air and I'm gonna use that
technique in this build because I want
this to feel like a gun when you shoot
it I don't want it to be like some janky
thing where you have to pull a lever and
like so having a trigger is crucial
having an accurate gun here I've drawn
out the actual PVC and pneumatic build
system it's all the functional parts and
then in blue I've highlighted the
aesthetic parts made of wood and other
rifle parts all that stuff that will be
added on top of that to kind of give the
gun a sniper rifle feel the Nerf darts
slightly smaller than the actual PVC
pipe so I'm not sure if the air is gonna
flow around that rather than propel the
dart
hunting Firenze and I think I see one I
think this is really gonna work if we
have some pneumatic everybody went to
Home Depot got all the PVC parts that I
needed and then it was just a matter of
kind of fitting them together basically
right now what I have to do is put the
basic assembly they gun together so I'm
not gonna glue anything together quite
yet I'm just gonna cut it piece them
together that's the great thing about
working with PVC and then I can see kind
of how big it is how it's gonna feel
before I get started I just can I help
you this isn't gonna work
this I've made millions of these before
these you know silly airsoft guns and
you know I know how these things work
but the way you're building it that's
just never gonna work I'm sorry maybe
I'd be a little bit more research and
back to the drawing board and whatnot
cuz I know science I'm a science guy to
be frank there's a lot of reasons I
don't think Nick is really up to the
task of building a gun but I think the
most important one is that he's just not
really the brightest guy and he's got a
lot of strengths it's just you know I
haven't found any of them yet but this
is definitely not this intelligence is
not one of them let's say that you're so
confident it's not gonna work then once
I finish building it you can stand in
front of it fine I don't care
I mean there's nothing to worry about
right it's not gonna work is that
allowed I'm technically not gonna shoot
you because yeah yeah I know it's not
gonna work so that's a deal that yeah I
sure are you recording this all right
yeah uh yeah that's deal cool shake on
it man okay
all right so I cut down the air tank
let's see how it feels once I kind of
pop it together here there the drill is
not here yet but the drill will clamp
right here it's still a little bit long
I can cut it shorter because technically
this whole thing is all the air tank so
there's gonna be pressurized air stored
in this whole area here and it's only
gonna be released at this valve point
right here yeah I think I'm gonna cut it
down a little bit more actually I did a
second cut down of the air tank feels
pretty good should work we have incoming
whenever Andrew Allen comes over he
tries to assault the compound
I got armaments and they got skilled
tactical soldiers so it's gonna be a
fight I wish I had some sort of device
some weapon to accurately shoot Andrew
with some really accurate long-range
actually Ren was on his phone and that's
the reason I believe he might be here
right now last time and realms come over
Brenda's been his cohort who's getting
an information from the inside he's a
double agent we all know it if it ain't
Rena dict Arnold himself dude I've never
had a gun so you
the camera how'd it go under the camera
than up at his head you might think we
take nerve too seriously but we also
make a living ever making cool videos
nerf guns in them so you know it all
works out
so now that the drills arrived I can
actually make sure everything's going to
fit taking out the motor of
disconnecting the wires and then
attaching those wires to the sprinkler
valve how do we not have any Phillips
head screwdrivers why are all these
screws you could use this this would
work
it's a flathead screwdriver but that'll
work we're gonna rip everything out
including the motor we're gonna figure
out which wires connect to the motor and
then reroute those to this valve here
yeah a successful test is that this
opens up it'll just click okay if it's
not successful we just won't hear
anything ready so bleed again you got a
boo-boo
no yes right there and I literally just
screw it on I can actually shorten this
I'm trying to make this middle part here
as compact as I can because I don't want
the gun to be like oh I want you to
actually be able to hold it like a real
rifle and have it be comfortable it's
coming together man I was scared that
wasn't gonna work all right so now that
I have all the pieces together here the
physical pieces it's time to actually
prime and cement everything together
with some PVC primer and PVC cement
before I take it apart I'm gonna label
each part how it connects together I
don't want there to be any mistakes
because once it's cemented together it's
actually going to melt the plastic and
there's no going back from there so I
can't [ __ ] up
so PVC is like really smooth and that
doesn't really take well to binding ages
so what this primer is actually gonna do
is on a very microscopic level turn the
smooth PVC plastic into a rough surface
that is better for binding things
together so it took me a little bit but
I got everything cemented together and
now it's looking like I have a real
pneumatic air cannon I'm super excited
so I'm gonna put the drill on I'm gonna
wire it up and then I'm gonna do my
first test actually shooting it to make
sure it works or
alright alright alright if you noticed
that there was a CMD on here then okay
you're a superfan he did it crack the
code tried to bamboozle you and you saw
right through it
no there's no bamboozles no bamboozles I
promise okay let's let's let's turn back
the clock here few days ago I said there
wasn't a logo this was an unbranded hat
it's technically correct though if you
do think this is a cool design that's
still on sale for two more days head
over to order digital comm slash store
and up for yourself
it also comes in black and green which i
think is even cooler if this doesn't
work then I have to start over or just
scrap the project I can't take it apart
there should be some area here yeah you
got me on this one Dobie
that's right ready it works ok that's
like a huge weight off my shoulders
because now I can go to the fun part
which is the aesthetic stage of this
build the stock the wood furniture the
scope the muzzle brake all that stuff
now for these things I found bits and
pieces around the studio we also have a
boneyard of airsoft gun parts that I
kind of picked through and then I'm
going to take some side paneling from an
old nerf gun we have and kind of put
that over the piping so it doesn't quite
look like I'm holding a bunch of
plumbing pipe I think it'll be really
fun kind of doing some sort of physical
kit bash here to make this look like a
cool piece of weaponry all right so the
kit bash is going along pretty well this
thing's looking pretty freakin sweet oh
man I'm just kind of like adding more
parts to it and kind of fleshing the gun
out I mean he's he's basically just
glued together a bunch of nerf parts to
try to make something that looks cool
but I don't think there's actually any
like functionality to it what is that
and the jank is pretty strong with this
one
but I think it looks pretty friggin
sweet how do you think the guys are
gonna react I think they're gonna be
like you went too far freakin sweet
the gun worked but it worked he said he
already tested it took his gun worked
I'm just gonna go get I'm just gonna
what Oh what's up man
whoa why are you in here can I just see
the camera real quick I just want to see
I just want to look at the footage
really close they can just give me the
camera I just I just okay I don't have
to do the whole shooting thing it's a
pretty dumb bit anyway right that's okay
I guess I just want to see the footage
that's up look if you mean you both say
that the deal never happened maybe we
can convince a Nick he's not very smart
we can probably just convince him that
he made up the memory all right okay so
this thing's looking pretty dang cool
right now
I'm gonna go paint it up now and then
it's time to actually fire the thing he
over up to me I would hit the door and
then drop back to the loading dock door
make sure I come in undetected I'd get
out these three people before they sit
Jake's is clear up front I'm pretty sure
I saw somebody with a gun walking around
over there the key to surviving a nerf
ambush is to remain calm
what was that nikka be careful man
you see anything
you were a great guard in through the
door that was already locked
that means this had been opened from the
inside all right the gun build is
complete it is Monday today on Friday I
was supposed to test this gun but for
some reason Danny was sick he didn't
come into work he seems fine today he's
here I'm gonna test this gun out and
Danny is gonna be in front of the barrel
as the target like I said before I'm not
really big on guns but come on this is
so cool look on the scope I'm just not
sure if it's actually gonna be accurate
and powerful time to test fire oh is it
no no it's just I didn't know they're
shooting a video with that this is the
gun man it's done let's take a human yes
one you said I couldn't make remember
because I'm stupid I don't think I said
that karma Phil did I say that yeah you
just meet me back there okay okay yeah
sweet you down in one second no armor
yeah okay well would you just leave me
alone for a second up here give it you
have a man of my word
yeah man yeah I think it's all gonna go
pretty well right guys let's do this I'm
ready to go I'll go stand over there far
away I just got my new sunglasses you've
been working out breath yeah a lot
actually thanks is it detailed that's
why I wear this hoodie is yes it really
just shows off my physique so I'd say
there's about point zero three percent
chance a little work I'd say those are
good odds man
alright Danny let me know when you're
rollin three two wooden Danny okay give
nail them like right in the gut just
like I'd say that's a success right
there
[Music]
and for tradition on the 70 go channel
if you make something that shoots you
have to be shot by it Nick your turn I
need a Power Cell yeah no I took the
wind out of you dude
yeah I could tell you we're like a
little breathless at first it's very
satisfying I pulled the trigger and it
shot out there is no recoil well it
looked true from my perspective
yeah I mean where I was aiming and no
hard feelings about that right